-Police in Idaho on Saturday
arrested 31 people
who are allegedly members
of the white-supremacist group,
the Patriot Front,
after they were caught
outside a Pride parade.
The group was hiding inside a
U-Haul truck, wearing riot gear,
and was apparently planning to
attack the event.
-Police were tipped off by what
they called a concerned citizen
who said they witnessed what
looked like a little Army.
the group hopped into a U-Haul,
in the back of a hotel parking
lot, wearing masks, shields,
and shin guards.
All 31 members were charged with
conspiracy to riot.
-One of my writers,
Jenny Hagel, is gay,
and she's here to comment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Seth.
This news is really upsetting.
Pride events should be joyful
celebrations,
not targets for hate
and violence.
The people arrested this weekend
are awful human beings.
Also, they're a bunch of dorks.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry, "dorks"?
-Yeah.
They were going to attack a
Pride parade in Idaho,
an event attended by literally
hundreds?
[ Laughter ]
Okay, tough guys.
The only place with fewer queer
people is a Talbots.
[ Laughter ]
Come try that [Bleep] at the
Pride parade in New York,
attended by 2 million people
who spend the rest
of the year at the gym.
[ Laughter ]
Also, these idiots got arrested
before they even
committed the crime.
What a bunch of nerds!
[ Laughter ]
When I was in high school,
I got grounded for
staying at Denny's past curfew,
but at least I got to the
Denny's.
[ Laughter ]
These guys weren't even found
out by the police or the FBI.
They were caught when a random
citizen called in a tip.
That is the dorkiest thing I've
ever heard.
That's like trying to rob a bank
and getting stopped
by a crossing guard.
[ Laughter ]
I will say one thing, though.
The thing that really upset me
about this attack
was how personal it was.
They really got us in the place
that was most vulnerable.
-You mean Pride month?
-No, I mean a U-Haul.
[ Laughter ]
They tried to attack queer women
by jumping out of a U-Haul,
the chosen form of
transportation for lesbians.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
And I'm sorry,
why is that, again?
-Because we move in together
very quickly.
We've been over this, Seth.
-Okay, yeah, sorry, sorry.
I'm sorry. continue.
-But the worst part of this
whole thing
is that these guys
were gonna attack in khakis.
That's our uniform!
[ Sighs ]
That's like if the Nazis tried
to catch the Von Trapps
while wearing curtains.
[ Laughter ]
Truly a low blow.
Look, here's the thing.
It's pride month, and it's easy
to feel sometimes like the fight
for LGBTQ+ rights is over.
But the arrest this weekend
reminds us that queer people
still need protection from state
and federal governments
and from our allies.
It shows us that there are
people out there who think
America is for a small, dorky
few, instead of for everyone.
And worst of all,
it shows us that
you can't always trust
a U-Haul.
[ Laughter ]
-Jenny Hagel, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much, Jenny!